tai ji tiens bâclage suis surtout
répertoire je crois qu acteur au hasard
c'est parti allez on y va
bîmes attention du monde à wismes c'est
qu'ils allaient flavie flament non c'est
drôle sans rigoler alors gemini mathy je
tombais sur me wade
mais matthew tu les feras tu l'as vu mon
cul allez c'est parti à laquelle
répondra castaldi allez on y va conçu la
partie mais mathy satan maire et maire
de nice est devenu marchand ainsi mimie
mathy matinée mathis est parti du likoud
droite
oui allez vas-y tu fais tu de vue mon
cas ça va mini tout ça après j'ai points
le paraguay en france ah ouais ce que tu
connais la sonnerie était vrai il sort
d'où toi c'est en toi je vous aime
après je prends je prends le bénin et
lille me passerais tu ton portable
beinheim c'est bien une passe bien mais
ça ne plaît pas je dis bon anniversaire
du poney anniversaire mais c'est pas du
tout son anniversaire du sommet
bah oui à delormeau mon frère m'avait
jamais qu'elle soit élue miss c'était
benji je me savoir si tous avaient revu
voilà donc avec cette situe la revue
rappelle moi elle aurait même le message
allez on passe à beinheim avait revu
rappelle moi je tapais c'est un avis
alors on va le faire après avec vos
attentions
on le fait attention c'est parti allez
on y va même ces partis top alors je
sais pas qui s'est débattue et 10 et
valérie bénaïm et tu les fais attendant
c'est un numéro fixe non alors on fait
tac attention bim
tu vois bien cet aréna toi khabar
assitante jérôme fouqueray w9 c'est
parti je la connais la connais très bien
une bonne cause et où c'est une petite
brune avec une coupe au carré on y va on
l'appelle
elle me connaît pas ouvrir situées à
basse et valérie bénaïm j'aimerais
prendre rendez vous récurrent de foucré
sinon tu la revue toi ta maman ça prend
quelqu'un d'autre je sais pas mais palm
oil allégeance au début on s'en fout si
on veut pas des people taxé par
catherine barma la productrice n'est pas
conseillé numéro je pense à ces partis
n'ont attaqué pas non non non c'est le
bon passage de catherine barbaroux tu
dis ça va catherine barma celle de cyril
hanouna
non mais je travaille toujours excellent
même si j'aimerais bien prendre rendez
vous avec toi y'a pas de ticket pour la
laponie aujourd'hui si justement je vais
vous expliquer comme ayant un ticket
pour la paix oui bonjour catherine c'est
valérie bénaïm à l'appareil c'est
valérie bénaïm sava catherine bonjour
comment ça là bas je venais un petit peu
aux nouvelles et je voulais savoir si tu
sais je travaille toujours avec ses
rythmes et jouer savoir si on pouvait
éventuellement se voir un de ces jours
mais pour quelles raisons valérie ce
serait avec plaisir répondre bah écoute
simplement reprise de contact j'ai envie
un peu de voir est un peu de se parler
quoi ah bah écoute génial mais je ne
voudrais pas je voudrais pas que ça ait
l'air non il écoute il est tout à fait
d'accord il n'y a aucun souci il peut
plus me voir façon donc
donc voilà d'accord et sinon dix mois
catherine est ce que tu la revue 4
catherine barma c'est cyril hanouna
alors on faisait un truc on a chaud avec
le broad perd toit et de valérie meriem
on est tombé sur vous et catherine tu
peux voir valérie je ne me fâche pas du
tout et j'espère que nous aussi on va se
voir sans est parti sur de mauvaises
bases tous les deux non mais attends et
j'aimerais comprendre si génial
l'accord cacao mais oui catherine tél
oui bah oui bah oui on a en direct
catherine donc on t'embrasse et valérie
bénaïm c'est va s'excuser mais oui
messieurs c'est toi qui m'a fait faire
des conneries alors on sait que j'ai
fait c'était c'est une vanne voilà mais
c'était tête était super 4 i say the
ladder non c'est que tu n'as pas du tout
elle matière est un trident t'embrasse
fort je vous embrasse très fort car ici
bah oui bon on te fait des gros bisous
catherine mois qu'on négocie les pirates
ou alors tous les chroniqueurs vous la
rendez vous au bon temps bradford
embrasse moi ça de 4.260 bisous non elle
adore elle reçoit était sympathiquement
après halal ou pas elle a eu la réaction
de l'as rome qui la première chose
qu'elle a dit ça je veux pas de problème
avec ces mecs là franchement pas mal moi
la catherine marc à l'appui 20 points
[Applaudissements]
enfin dernier tu l'as vu en fin d'année
tu le halo et allez on y va
merci merci mais pour toi mais des mecs
le répertoire attend hallyday attend
surtout sur nos banques et non mais
attention c'est parti mathieu delormeau
n'est que des vies de choses ici est
quelqu'un qui répondent mais bon
attention à ces qui harris with mais
sinon je suis tombé sur une adresse
easigas c'est qu'ils aiment ça c'est
qu'on oublie c'est vrai personne
c'était un rêve attention c'est parti
toi c'est quoi la marque coach vert à
ces bons médecins et ben non
s'il vous plaît pas certes ça on y va si
on l'appelle à laisser ma mère mais il a
dit oui d'habitants s'étaient ils
habitent tous ici marque que je fais et
non mais tu vas tomber sa secrétaire
il répond pas en fait c'est le
brouillard je fais des tractations alors
j'ai un autre mec
sébastien lecornu c'est qui le camp du
oui c'est le rdr est bon là on a fait le
corps ont caché chez les minimes on est
passé de 2 sur 7
fayard numéro masqué que t'as pas je
réponds à loos alors qu'il
oui oui je suis tapé pour savoir si tu
l'avais vu l'éclipsé kingson cap capelle
sur le portable de deux ans mort ce
moment là mon numéro mais c'est bien
aussi
autant ça allait moins cher et je
t'embrasse
c'est kaka mais j'écoute mais je sais
pas un regard et tout le monde vous
appelle alors on appelle sébastien le
camp religion au numéro non pas ne
connaît bien le candidat en appel le
corps alors non tu là alors on fait pas
tu l'as vu tu l'étais genre c'est son
anniversaire tuer je vais dire bonne
elle n'a pas dû tourner anniversaire la
bnm a été fabuleux dis moi qui réponds
pas s'ils répondent pas le top mais si
tu laisses un bon anniversaire si c'est
sébastien bon anniversaire et et tu
demandes et ce qu'il a vu ta numéro du
ministre koné haut et qui répond pas
mais il ya même pas de répondre à je
connais la date on conseille d'y aller
on en fait un dernier avec le pm c'est
parti on enfin dernier allez c'est parti
bim et à quoi à frédéric lopez bd
frédéric c'est quoi le sac et de quoi
c'est insulter un juge peut plus elle je
peux plus à ken ham est alors dit lui
qu'il embrasse
pourquoi lui apprécié outre abattu le
révérend et à quelle radio si j'étais la
dernière de quoi et étudie ça si tu dis
comment on peut aider vous en afrique
est une personne me répondre ouais et
sur thème chaque personne rythme
indolent moins rationnel le dernier il
me dit qu'il y avait un temps tu
remarqué dechavanne qu'apple tu réponds
pas buzzer allez on y va
c'est parti on a hâte à via davia
martelly s'est qui connaît pas anthony
martin passé celle d'isabelle ses chefs
c'est parti haïti n'est pas tout
c'est la chef d'isabelle a laissé le
dernier on dira après je vous décris
qu'est comment gagner le billet pour les
impôts ni on va se retrouver juste après
allez c'est parti
c'est le chef d'isabelle il va répondre
il va te répond lui c'est sûr c'est
certain allez on y va personne ne te
réponds toi quand même tombe pas en
panne la nuit et a le charisme la
sagesse et où six personnes répondent
aux amis sur twitter twitter qui
marquait un dernier but à martin veut
pas faire sauter métal et un dernier je
le veux je veux aller yahaya michou
michou ychoux arrive à dire à michel n'a
pas quatre ans attend des méchants et là
on fait aller oui on y va monsieur
michel c qui bannissait monsieur michel
japonais mary murphy
ce n'est pas non pas pierre palmade non
merci
falafel pellegrino annoncé avec de télé
réalité on top sophie pendeville mais
c'est faux ça c'est une animatrice belge
non mais avait allez on y va un dernier
allez vas-y on y va julien poinas assez
un producteur assez un producteur
bonbonnes baird nom est apparu normal
t'as pas intérêt à bas par des gens que
nice olivier boulette sur le pote du
goût acquise à le sénat mais certaines
kaka attention attention à l'air dernier
un dernier vous avez le faire on va le
faire sous la fenêtre pierre robert sait
qui c'est pierre robert sur un seul
patron de w9 que le frère de victor
robert
allez on y va à l'arrêt et on y va c'est
parti tu l'appelles et tu nous fais un
tu l'as vu mon cul
mais en plus et tu rappelles que ce soir
et access parce que d'y accéder
producteurs d'accès sien c'est pas super
les balais vanille tu dis qu'il se soit
cassé
il accède sur la promo et tout est frais
pompage et c'est d'après moi aussi très
bon en toi c'est la touche pas tatouage
fumée mais je crois qu'il est donc pour
toi je vais essayer de mettre plus le
même mais qu'elle aura pas de graves
tensions des autres à l'hôtel à la
gourmette en cela redescend un peu light
and on va voir que tu ais je suis allé
faire un tour à la télé téléphone tu
verras on est maintenant on regarde la
taille de ton cerveau
attention attention j'appelle le même
mais que watts c'est le producteur
d'accès sur un pont personnes allô allô
pierre comment ça va mon père on sait
cyril hanouna ça dure et ça va je te
dérange jamais merci mon pierrot
dis moi mon père il ya access ce soir
sur ces 8
merci tu seras devant ce soir l'épisode
il est fou ce soir avec ahmed un lot et
le premier il est top
alors il matthieu delormeau l'a vu il a
kiffé je te passe salut mon père ça va
oui déjà
félicitations j'ai adoré la série et 10
mois à propos d'ailleurs si jamais il ya
enfin un rôle ou quoi ce que je peux me
disponible à l'eau avec grands noms mais
voilà si jamais en tous les cas ça
j'aimerais beaucoup le temps que j'adore
amène en plus et du coup ça c'est
vraiment très plaisir et en plus je ne
sais pas du tout être mais je ne sais
pas d'ailleurs si tu la revue toi non
mon cul
[Rires]
côté messin en revanche c'était vrai de
vous que je veux bien jouer dans la
série on t'aime on sera tous devant
access on sera tous devant axel se joue
au foot droite - chéri d'amour
j'ai vu des couverts